so here's our here's our closing
question and then I'm going to save the
rest of these for our second film maker
question stream
holy mackerel the third asks if you have
any tips on enthusiasm the thing they
find hardest is getting started writing
or planning and have trouble following
through on projects I know this is
something a lot of creative people face
I really like to hear you talk about how
you deal with follow-through and
possibly schedule and when you don't
manage to keep up with those things how
you deal with that so I I had them still
like I don't keep them on my desk
anymore but I used to I have these two
little plush toys that I made like
they're just basically a little like
gingerbread men that I did I made out of
just some scrap fabric that I had lying
around and they're awful they're they're
terrible they're ugly and lopsided and
and hideous but I kept them on my desk
for years because they were started they
were part of a project that I started
about a year before I started making
this show which was a a motivation
project and what it was was you you come
up with a task a creative task and then
you have 24 hours to complete that task
and at the end of that 24 hours whatever
state it is in is done it's considered
done and so where this came from is I
had so back in high school I have these
creative writing classes that I took and
what I started to notice is that nobody
was ever finishing anything is that
everybody when it would come like time
for like a group sharing everyone would
be like all right well this is a novel
starter but here's here's the first half
of the first chapter and then they would
would share their thing and I was
doing this too like I am NOT blameless I
would do this too and so I was thinking
back on these and I was like you know
what what what I really need is is I
need to finish projects because the one
part of a project you know it's this is
an old canard like tons of people have
have pointed this out is the creative
people have this habit of starting
projects and never finishing them and
what I had realized is that that is
skill building is that you are learning
how to start projects and you get better
and better at starting projects but
because you're never finishing projects
you're not building the skill of
completing something you're you're not
building the skill of walking away from
something you're constantly in this
state of like okay well this is just a
beginning this is a start this is the
seed for something that will come later
and there are places for that but I I
knew that I needed to to find a place
where I could build skills on the other
end build the skills of finishing build
the skills of walking away and so you
had so that's the that's the thing you
come up with a creative task and you
have 24 hours to finish it and at the
end of that 24 hours it doesn't matter
what state it's in that state is you you
consider that state to be done it's not
oh well here's a good start of something
or if I put another 10 hours into this
it would be so much better it's like no
the state of this is is complete even if
it's awful even if it's bad even if it's
malformed even if it's broken it is done
and then you walk away from it and what
this did was this is a great task like
this is a great way of getting yourself
unjammed if you're having creative block
it's a great way of building skills for
the entire process you see this like
this is the underlying logic of things
like game jams and 24 hour Film Fest is
that it's like you know learning to to
finish something
learning to accept the things are done
and also helping yourself move away from
the emotional investment of like okay
this thing that I'm going to make is I
am going to come out onto the scene with
a bang I am going to make something
perfect and everyone will notice it and
it's like no now you you need to accept
some of the stuff that you're going to
make is going to suck some of it is
going to be things that you're not
ultimately that invested in like you
know you're doing it because you know
you need money because you're bored
because somebody asked you to because
like whatever like you're going to do
stuff you will end up making things for
reasons other than pure raw creative
passion and out of that you know when
when you can accept that when I can
accept that when I can get myself into a
place where it's like alright some of
the things I'm going to make are going
to be not great or are going to be just
kind of okay when you accept that then
you're able to actually make things and
so there's a point where like you know
you just kind of need to tell yourself
like alright just make something it
doesn't need to be good it just needs to
be done uh I would actually say that
like my all of the lights review that's
how it that was actually where it came
from is that so I did the memes I did
the memes episode in Australia and then
I cooked up a whole bunch of other ideas
and I shot like two of them and then
never finished them you know because I
got hung up on tiny little things like I
will be audios pretty bad and honestly
like I went back to review the footage
in the audio is terrible or they're like
nonsense like they were bad they were
bad I wasn't necessarily wrong for trash
canning them but it was then mid-2011 in
fact it was July it was July 2011 I was
sitting there and it was like okay I
have this whole idea I had script ideas
and I had things I wanted to talk about
and I had this puppet idea and I was
starting to build the pup
it and I had the prototype of the puppet
and it was just kind of this moment
where I was like you know what you can
spend the next year or two years pre
producing this idea because it's like oh
well I've got to get a better camera and
I've got to get a better microphone and
I've got to like really work on these
scripts and these scripts need to be so
good that like people are really going
to notice them once they're once they're
out there and I was I realized I was
getting hung up on that and I needed to
and it was like no you need to make
something this weekend and at the end of
the weekend it needs to be done and
you're going to put it out there and
walk away and so I did that I used Foley
and if you look at if you go back and
watch all the lights which you actually
can't now that I've said it out loud
because it's copyright claims but I
think the the if any of like the first
three like you can totally see the
puppet isn't done like not just you know
oh I continued to make changes to the
puppet it was like clearly not complete
and you know I I felt so anxious about
that at the time because it's like oh is
anybody going to notice this and in
retrospect it's like that was not the
important question because no no one was
going to notice it not really I mean
sort of but not really like what it was
supposed to look like yeah and so it
became it was like well no it ultimately
did become part of a like building
process and you know I mean I still go
through this all the time like people I
get a huge influx of people through one
source or another and I go you know and
I start then getting super worried about
like the things that I put out after
that like oh it needs to be up - it
needs to be like better otherwise all
these people are going to realize I'm a
fraud and they're gonna they're going to
run away and it's like that's not
actually that big of a risk like people
are willing to hang out through a lot of
things and like keeping things
proportional in terms of like what the
stakes actually are that is like none of
the stakes the stakes are not that high
you're not talking about like oh well
they gave me a hundred and fifty million
budget I better produce something that's
actually like good or they're never
going to hire me again it's like you're
making videos for the internet like
you're going to have to put out a couple
before anyone like really notices you
and if you put out 10 20 30 100 that are
like really kind of bad before you hit
your stride no one's going to care like
no one's going to hold you to it
no one's going to you know like if you
get that one that's like where you just
nail it and like it gets posted
everywhere and everyone shares it no
one's gonna like yeah people are going
to dive through your backlog but no
one's going to go oh man your old stuff
terrible unsubscribe you know they're
going to be as like oh well I already
subscribe for the new stuff like
presumably the new stuff is going to be
up to the Qualla tried least in the
neighborhood of the quality of the
newish like whatever they signed on for
and so you know just kind of go care
only and are we ever going to improve so
yeah in theory like ideally you're only
ever going to improve so so to make that
short how to get over that hump is to to
make a self thing just make something
and I would actually like really
recommend like pet projects will kill
you pet projects will will put you in
your grave murder your pet projects you
know one in every 10 pet project is
actually worth the effort that you put
into it and the others probably deserve
to either be like rushed out and
abandoned if not taken out behind the
shed and shot like most of the ideas
that we get fixated on as pet projects
are not nearly as good as we think they
are I mean most of my like I've gone
back and looked at some of my like my
babies just like someday this I will I
will carve this into a perfect finished
form and I go back and I look at my
notes and I look at like everything that
I was working on like god I can't I
can't believe I thought this was this
was my like
seeing that this was going to be the
thing that was going to make me and was
like no no this is an awful idea I'm
probably better for having not not made
this so yeah if you find yourself
becoming fixated on a project it's it it
is actually statistically a good sign
that it's a bad project you should walk
away like that sounds so bad but it's
like no kill your babies and kill your
heroes okay so to sum up the final
question guys just make [ __ ] Jimmy
babies yeah your hero
you heard it here from Dan this this is
advice for pushing forward so yeah